hey guys how's it going happy holidays
I'm back here with my sister hello this
is Jenna today we are drinking out of
our star laboratories mugs I was
watching the flash which I absolutely
love season - dr. wells I'm only on
season 2 so no spoilers but he was
drinking out of one of these mugs and I
was like oh I want to drink out of one
of those - I was actually here did that
happen she's like I want one of those -
gets on the internet showed up she's
like come on I ordered this cheers
Cheers
anyway we've got our mugs but today
we're doing nothing that has to do with
the flash or anything really why are we
wearing festive sweaters what are we
even doing today the holiday season and
we're celebrating all of December
it's vlogmas sort of I'm sort of longing
every I've missed a lot of day I'm not
sure oh the future maker what fortune oh
okay so this is a fortune cookie maker
and spoiler alert I've actually made
these before I'm thinking Jordan made
these ones but it wasn't even for a
video it was actually just for fun to
see if we could make them and now here
we are jenna is gonna assist me because
this process it's kind of crazy it was
easy yeah
we burned ourselves as so many times
like it's kind of insane and it's really
hard to do so I lied to you
what'd you burn yourself is that in the
instructions burn self you don't want to
do it but you do can I make my own
fortune yes
costing fortune cookies there's an
edible marker that this comes with I
have to write the fortunes if there's
not like a label maker I have so what I
thought would be a cool ideas if you
made these you could do little gifts for
people you could put like a little gift
certificate inside of it so like if you
get somebody to Amazon gift card you can
just like write the Amazon gift
cold I think what if they don't open it
believe baby song whatever the ink runs
then they miss these four questions that
are just too in-depth for what I feel
like going into it let's open it okay
here we go
yay fortune fun what's this I'm just
here I'm literally just here for the
cookie
I need a t-shirt that says I'm just here
for the cookies dad does it mean what
you think it means
does it mean something else yes good lit
in this kitchen look at this Wow Bam Bam
Bam I mean you're in my water
Bam Bam so this is the paper trash that
is like edible paper I think it's a bit
take a bite right yeah no it's not you
can eat it but it's like after you prove
to put you some edible paper
I retract it I retract Achatz I reset it
you must be the paper you track my
statement okay cool good all of our
little goodies we've gotten here that
this comes with we've got a little
slipper we've got an edible marker look
here's a caution for us cookies are hot
be careful handling cookies during the
folding process so to make our fortune
cookie recipe we're gonna need five
tablespoons of unsalted butter 1 cup
superfine sugar 1 pinch of salt 4 large
egg whites 1 cup all-purpose flour 5
tablespoons of milk 1 teaspoon vanilla
extract non cooking spray know I'm
cooking spray with non cooking spray
nonstick we need no I'm cooking spray we
need spray try to put this in the bowl
no yet we have to melt this so get that
melted up so can I put on the bowl no
melt it put it up don't I don't put it
in another bowl and melt the bowl
is there a reason yes because yet
because I have to put in the dry
ingredients and I really have an answer
for you I'm getting flustered forgot
about the butter
oh no super wet that's okay it needs to
be melted very melted when combined egg
white
and sugar you dummy
it was supposed to be egg whites I'm an
absolute idiot
I knew this as well well you said it and
I did say it Chloe
I like the small sugar I do not like to
smell of burnt butter
this is looking very nice yes yeah
especially yeah we need five tablespoons
of milk it might be expired how many
nights at five five we need to mix in
the vanilla vanilla nila how much shimmy
shimmy cocoa purpose cleaner table
teaspoon the first mix is the slowest
touch that could you imagine if I just
cut your hair no it's all I have going
for me okay well we need it right out
our fortune cookies am I making this for
you we can or we can make it for whoever
we want no I've got other edible markers
in here it's like who doesn't have
multiple other than markers okay this is
gonna be for Nick he's behind the camera
I'm gonna make one for him too okay well
I think we have enough just to get us
started
that's a great that's a good one fold as
directed you're not open the fortune
cookie maker before the recommended
cookie so don't open it before two
minutes it is two minutes
this smells really bad hey where the
hell did they go
Oh God oh my gosh that thing that's not
supposed to happen
oh my god oh god this wrench this looks
really bad that's not right
I just realized how completely worthless
I am in this video it's cool I'm just
like here and then I'm here and then I'm
over here this is going not as well as
it did before it could just be the first
couple that needs to get that yeah we
need to have to crack off with the true
we gotta warm it up I think I should
check on them you can okay okay okay
this whole thing like that's not what's
supposed to be happening
holy moly oh gosh is it hot and then you
just like pull it up like you're gonna
make one out of my way you're gonna
spray it in here no I might like make my
own practice this is a practice
this is horrible it's whoever thought
this was gonna work out well oh wow yeah
give me another hit of that oh yeah look
I couldn't break it because it Oh work
hard
are we gonna fortune in it yes okay this
looks it so far it's so hot it's so
uncredible hot okay so about this ready
nailed it hello-o burned into my finger
oh god I can't get it out okay
oh wow okay that wouldn't need a little
more batter
maybe this difficult slay do you want to
melt off our chocolate
I'm busy I just about an email half hour
three minutes
check on it every minute no see you have
to put in the minutes first and then the
power level
I made a want on why I messed up my
favorite thing is when you made a
pumpkin pie oh my god oh oh my god who
in the world was I told you is too much
that's right so upsetting it's not ideal
if a little me don't want is it hot I
don't want to touch it oh it's so
unbelievably hot okay here we go look at
that did you see that perfection this is
absolute fortune cookie perfection do
you remember the simple instruction that
I gave you also we have to check on the
chocolates at every minute well I
already missed two of the minutes
I know put your hand I'll give you 10
bucks 10 $10 we think about it so even
worth the hospital bill at that now that
I've got this technique down is to Bari
we okay well that looks good I'll put
that in there I was cleaning I pushed
the fortune cookie machine and I burned
myself so bad like my finger is actually
burning right like it hurts it doesn't
you can't really tell my gosh hurts
crime
okay here's our fortune cookies we got
the hang of it oh no that's our food
that's okay but we actually have the
hang of it like look how cookies look
there was a mistakes that I was making
another one of those who didn't wait too
much spray when I stopped using so much
spray things worked out quite well
oh my finger hurts so bad okay so
basically we're just gonna dip now watch
me don't even open yours when I make up
for you yeah mmm we need a presentation
plate look that that looks absolutely
beautiful let's give it to someone else
we did it for yours my dear sister my
dear sisters I've opened this I have an
injury there you know I got hurt today
guys I got an injury look at this one
we're gonna give him a nice little dead
oh my finger hurts really bad you're
gonna be hearing about this for like a
week you know she had the flu once I was
like oh actually no I'm not in the flow
should have like a cold like the most
common of colds
I was so ill and it was like someone
beat her with a bat I got I have it I
get a sickness
I make sure everyone knows about it look
at this dual cookie wow that looks nice
Jen thank you can you open that one
thank you color oh yeah but they're gems
I'm injured so Mike you know look at
this Wow
oops oops well I used some on one so now
what whoa here I'll make it
nope I hate it I don't like it I think
it looks good I can't touch him use my
finger hurts oh my god how many are we
having two three now three complaints
oh we did make a creep only stop bombing
oh yeah I have more eight it's done this
video I'm making look great
you've never seen you guys like actually
eat the stuff like you're enjoying it
it's so good wait do you want come be in
our video sure here you go
okay which one is it okay the black one
like my soul yeah there we go
it's still it's still sticky taste that
first taste it yeah because there's no
chocolate on it
now you need a fortune cookie
right why do you think we're literally
eating everything really good this is
for you I think if it's not then we have
to break it open it
um open it we should open it yeah
awkward cookies yes it is I don't know
but they're really good why am i card in
crap oh yeah he pees first right or is
bad luck yeah but you're not supposed so
guys uh Nick ate something that I make
not too long ago wakening
so you are not going to eat anything
that I ever made again I'm dairy free
year have a dairy free year oops
yeah well cancel okay that one's for you
it's really it's probably not dried yet
what the heck is this I can't open it
because my thumb her oh my god you will
pay Jenna the money you owe her Oh
fortune fun oh no you will find a clown
hidden somewhere oh don't bring me it on
that we have to ice my thumb because I
thought a boo-boo
I'm starting to get a blister might look
at my injury oven hot to touch oh oh I
do it with a needle oh no all right guys
thank you so much for watching you have
you guys enjoyed this video happy
holidays Merry Christmas whatever you
celebrate I hope that you are
celebrating it with festivity and style
I've got one last thing make sure you go
check out Jenna's channel and yeah
that's that's a wrap all I got a tummy
ache I had too many sweets these are so
good
I can't believe it we finally got the
hang of it at the end we need to work on
our decorating though cuz this is trash
we do hmm all right I'll see you guys in
the next video we'll have a bunch more
holiday videos coming out very shortly
so stay tuned
happy vlogmas sort of video every day in
December or until Christmas vlog maybe
vlog mmm maybe look yeah [ __ ] man man ok
[Music]
[Music]